here are the nominees for achievement in
art direction the artist production
design by Lawrence Bennett and set
decoration by Robert Gould Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows part-2
production design by Stuart Craig and
set decoration by Stephanie McMillan
Hugo production design by Dante Ferretti
and set decoration by Francesco
Loschiavo Midnight in Paris production
design by on Savelle and set decoration
by Ellen Dubrow warhorse
productive design by Rick Carter and set
decoration by Lise and dales and the
Oscar goes to Hugo
Dante Ferretti production designer for
Costello JaVale set decoration
this is the third Academy Award for a
husband-and-wife team Dante Ferretti and
still no shovel they took home their
first two Oscars in this category for
The Aviator and Sony time
thank you to the Academy for this
prestigious award a great thank you goes
to the producer Graham King and Tim
Eddington
- oh my our department but the most of
all my very special thank you to a chap
channel director who guide us through
this wonderful journey Martin Scorsese
thank you thank you thank you very much
this is for Martina and for Italy